[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara
hallweg guten Abend schön dass Sie dabei
sind wie auch Norbert Lehmann für den
Sport ein schön guten Abend auch von mir
wir haben unter anderem diese Themen für
Sie Streitthema Staatsfinanzen nach dem
Urteil zu den coronakrediten drohen der
Ampel jetzt noch weitere Milliarden
Löcher Wechsel in Argentinien ein
Rechtspopulist gewinnt die
Präsidentschaftswahl und kündigt an das
Land radikal
umzubauen Schluss nach nur zwei Jahren
die Ratsvorsitzende der Evangelischen
Kirche Kurschus tritt zurück weil
umstritten ist wie früh sie von einem
Verdacht sexueller Übergriffe
wusste die Bundesregierung steht vor
einer weiteren
Zerreißprobe seit der Entscheidung des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts vergangene
Woche ist klar dass im Haushalt
mindestens 60 Milliarden Euro fehlen
vielleicht sogar noch mehr weil
möglicherweise noch andere sogenannte
Sondervermögen von dem Urteil betroffen
sind wie dieses Loch gestopft werden
kann ob durch krasses sparen mehr
Schulden oder höhere Steuern daran
scheiden sich die Geister Daniel
ponzen vieles ist noch unklar im
Regierungsviertel etwa wie groß die
Finanzlücke für die Ampel am Ende
tatsächlich wird denn allein beim Klima
und transformationsfond könnte neben den
nun gestrichenen 60 Milliarden Euro auch
schon eine frühere Bereitstellung
betroffen sein 26 Milliarden aus 2020
und zudem Gelder des
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfonds allein
dieses Jahr flossen daraus schon jetzt
mehr als 31 Milliarden sehr groß ist
also in jedem Fall die Lücke sehr groß
auch die Differenzen innerhalb der Ampel
wie dem Problem zu begegnen
sei alles ist auf dem Tisch aber es ist
auch gleichzeitig klar die Lücke die
jetzt
beim Geld da ist die lässt sich nicht
hauptsächlich durch Sparen schließen äh
und in dieser Höhe kann ja gar nicht
eingespart werden sparen bzw
priorisieren ist laut FDP sehr
wohlmittel der Wahl ein neuerliches
umgehen oder auch eine Umgestaltung der
Schuldenbremse dagegen nicht ich habe
das Urteil aus
Karlsruhe anders verstanden das Urteil
ist für uns ein Anlass die Schulden zu
stärken das Urteil ist kein Anlass um
die Schuldenbremse zu umgehen oder zu
schwächen anders sehen das viele auch in
der SPD die sich derwal kategorisch
verwartt gegen Kürzungsvorschläge etwa
beim
Bürgergeld manches was ich da jetzt
hören darf Vorschläge nach Sozialabbau
oder ähnlichem da muss ich klar sagen
dafür ist die Sozialdemokratie nicht
gewählt worden so etwas wird nicht
unsere Antwort auf die Herausforderung
der letzten Tage sein sollte es für die
Bürger werden etwa wenn die
energiepreisbremsen aus dem
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfond Wegfallen
sieht der Wirtschaftsminister die Schuld
dafür bei der Union sie hatte in
Karlsruhe geklagt das heißt aber im
Klartext dass jedenfalls für die Zukunft
die Bürgerin und bürgerhöhere Strom und
gegebenenfalls hohere Gaspreise bekommen
werden also die danke schreiben die
können die gleich an die Union richten
und Friedrich Merz nicht zustellen das
ist völliger Blödsinn die Ampel hat
diese Situation selbst zu verantworten
sie hat rechtsbiedrig gebucht und sie
hat dazu eine falsche buchungsregel
sogar in ihren Koalitionsvertrag
reingeschrieben dieser miese Trick ist
jetzt aufgefallen und durch das
Bundesverfassungsgericht aufgehoben
worden da ist niemand anders dran Schuld
als die Ampel selbst wie die Ampel ein
gemeinsamen pfahrt aus der aktuellen
Lage finden will auch das bleibt der
weil noch unklar ja fragen wir gleich
die Hanna Zimmermann in Berlin wie kommt
die Regierung raus aus diesem
Dilemma also auf jeden Fall gehen sie es
nicht mit ein einem gemeinsamen
Schulterschluss an viel mehr wird der
Ton deutlich rauer der
Wirtschaftsminister hat dem
Finanzminister heute Gerede vorgeworfen
weil der gesagt hat man könnne das
Problem durch Sparen lösen das ginge bei
den vielen Milliarden die nun
tatsächlich im Haushalt fehlen nicht
sagte habbeck eine Idee ist heute in den
Vordergrund gerückt und war
Gesprächsthema nämlich die Ausrufung
einer Notlage manche Verfassungsrichter
sind der Rechtler sind der Ansicht dass
eine solche Notlage von Karlsruhe nicht
aus lossen wurde wenn sie denn jährlich
neu begründet wird und so könnten Corona
und die der Ukraine Krieg als Begründung
dafür herhalten doch neue Gelder
außerhalb der Schuldenbremse locker zu
machen die Ampel braucht dafür nur eine
einfache Mehrheit im Bundestag
allerdings wir haben es gerade gesehen
die FDP sieht dieses Urteil in Karlsruhe
als Stärkung der schultenbremse und
möchte Schluss machen mit Hintertürchen
und sondertöpfchen aus dem Dilemma
allerdings kommt die Ampel so erstmal
nicht heraus danke schön für diese
Einschätzung Diana Zimmermann aus Berlin
an einem Versprechen haben sich schon
mehrere Regierungen die Zähne
ausgebissen endlich die Digitalisierung
voranbringen Digitalisierung meint z.B
dass man sein Auto per Computer ummelden
kann statt zur Zulassungsstelle zu gehen
auf EU-Ebene landet Deutschland hier nur
im Mittelfeld platz 13 von 27 ganz vorn
Finnland und Dänemark Bund und Länder
beteuern nicht zum ersten Mal beim Umbau
der Behörden jetzt Gas zu geben vom
digitalgipfel in Jena berichten Melanie
ha und Mona
trebing warten im Bürgeramt was in
anderen Ländern flächendeckend online
möglich ist geht in Deutschland noch
immer oft nur vor Ort online wde
natürlich vieles vereinfachen g ich muss
heute doch freinhmen extra um mir
herzukommen eigentlich sollte das längst
überflüssig sein hätte das sogenannte
online zugangsgesetz von 2017 so
gegriffen wie die Politik sich das
vorgenommen hatte bis Ende letzten
Jahres sollten 575 Verwaltungsleistungen
digital verfügbar sein stand jetzt sind
es
145 nun sollen 15 fokusleistungen
priorisiert werden wie Baugenehmigung
Ummeldung oder Elterngeld Volker Wissing
sieht hier auf dem digitalgipfel in Jena
seine Strategie trotzdem auf
Kurs die digitalstrategie ist schon in
der Umsetzung vieles ist schon
realisiert und noch mehr ist schon
angepackt das zentrale der
digitalstrategie ist ja dass wir
entscheidende Punkte fokussieren das
unterscheidet uns auch von früheren
Bundesregierung dass wir eben nicht uns
verzetteln nicht verzetteln in Zeiten in
denen andere Länder weiter sind und neue
Herausforderungen warten wie künstliche
Intelligenz zwar kommen etwa Glasfaser
und Breitbandausbau voran doch Kommunen
und Schulen hinken nach wie vor hin her
der Gedanke dass Digitalisierung eine
Investition in die Zukunft ist der ist
noch nicht durchgängig weder in der
Bundesregierung noch in den Ländern noch
in den Kommunen sonst wäre der
gemeinsame Kraftakt ja längst
durchgesetzt bis
2025 will die Bundesregierung mit der
digitalstrategie unter die Top 10 in
Europa kommen noch ist es das
Mittelfeld der digitalstandort
Deutschland um 19:30 Uhr auch Thema bei
ZF heute live im
Exklusivinterview Jonas andrulis Gründer
und Chef des KI Startups Alif Alpha zu
sehen in der heute App und in unseren
Social Media
Kanälen zum Krieg im Nahen Osten da gibt
es ja die vorsichtige Hoffnung dass von
der Hamas in den Gazastreifen entführte
Geiseln freigelassen werden könnten als
Gegenleistung für eine Feuerpause
darüber wird verhandelt bislang aber
ohne greifbares Ergebnis die israelische
Armee hat an angekündigt ihre Angriffe
noch mal auszuweiten l
walpot israelische Truppen Rücken weiter
in gazastadt vor dabei soll es nach
palästinensischen Angaben auch zum
Beschuss einer von Indonesien
finanzierten Klinik mit 12 Toten
gekommen sein unabhängig überprüfen
lassen sich die Zahlen nicht gestern
hatte die Armee diese Bilder
veröffentlicht sie sollen einen Tunnel
der Hamas am weitläufigen alschifer
Krankenhaus zeigen auch Geiseln habe die
Hamas in die Klinik verschleppt Bilder
der angeblichen Kommandozentrale der
Terroristen wurden nicht
gezeigt Hamas hat unsere Geiseln ins
schifahrhospital verschleppt und
ermordet Hamas hat terrortunnel unter
dem Krankenhaus
errichtet diese Frühgeborenen Babys
wurden heute am Grenzübergang Rafa zur
Behandlung nach Ägypten gebracht sie
waren am Samstag aus der umkämpften
alschiferklinik Richtung Süden evakuiert
worden wir mussten das Kind im
Brutkasten zurücklassen als wir in den
Süden flüeten wir dachten das Baby ist
dort in Sicherheit dass das Krankenhaus
angegriffen wurde kam für uns als Schock
an der Schicksal ihrer entführten Kinder
erinnerten Familien der israelischen
Geiseln am Abend anlässlich des
Weltkindertages darunter Angehörige von
qu und Ariel Bibers 10 Monate und 4
Jahre alt seit se Wochen in der Hand der
Hamas
Terroristen die internationale
Staatengemeinschaft muss mehr Druck
aufbauen auf die Hamas damit diese
Kinder jetzt freikommen
am Abend wollen die Familien mit
Regierungsvertretern Zusammentreffen die
Verhandlungen zur Freilassung eines
Teils der Geiseln brachten bislang keine
Ergebnisse Argentinien steht vor einem
historischen Regierungswechsel
überraschend deutlich hat dort ein
Rechtspopulist die Präsidentschaftswahl
gewonnen sein Name Javier my
selbsternannte
anarchokapitalist er übernimmt
Argentinien mitten in einer schweren
Wirtschaftskrise um 1900 war das Land
eines der reichsten der Welt heute liegt
die Inflationsrate bei mehr als
140% und fast die Hälfte der Bevölkerung
lebt in Armut m will Argentinien nun
radikal umbauen mehr von Christoph
röckerat es ist ein Jubel wie in Buenos
Aires seit dem wmsieg nicht mehr erlebt
hat Argentinien steht vor einem
radikalen politischen Neuanfang das
zumindest verspricht der neugewählte
Präsident von heute an ist Schluss mit
dem Staat der allmächtig ist der Armut
produziert und von dem nur wenige
profitieren während die Mehrheit der
Argentinier leidet ab heute ist Schluss
damit dass die Politiker und ihre
Freunde sich das Land
aufteilen Argentinien leidet unter
rekordinflation und Wirtschaftskrise
viele Wähler haben das Vertrauen in die
etablierte Politik
verloren wir brauchen den Wandel so wie
bisher kann es unmöglich weitergehen wir
haben ernsthaft ans Auswandern
gedacht ich habe ihm meine Stimme
gegeben weil ich will dass mein Sohn
eine Zukunft hat ich glaube an ihn sie
sagen er ist verrückt aber mir ist ein
Verrückter lieber als jemand der uns
weiter
beklaut die Kettensäge ist das
marktenzeichen des studierten Ökonomen
sein Versprechen das Establishment zu
Kleinholz verarbeiten die Zentralbank
und zahlreiche Ministerien abschaffen
den Dollar als Währung einführen
hauptsache alles anders Argentinien
steht vor einem politischen
Experiment gemindliche Stärke dass er
ein Quereinsteiger in die Politik ist
ist auch seine Schwäche denn er ist
wenig erfahren und kaum vernetzt für
seine radikalen Vorhaben aber braucht er
Verbündete und Mehrheiten im Parlament
nach dem Jubel kehrt der Alltag zurück
und mit ihm noch größere Erwartungen an
die künftige Regierung
Argentiniens zurück nach Deutschland
nach nur Z Jahren im Amt ist die
Vorsitzende der evangelischen Kirche
Annette Kurschus zurückgetreten
Hintergrund sind Verdachtsfälle gegen
einen ehemaligen Kirchenmitarbeiter es
geht um sexuelle Übergriffe das ganze
ist lange her kurschuss ist mit der
Familie befreundet sie sagt sie habe
damals allein die Homosexualität und
sexuelle Untreue des Mannes wahrgenommen
und erst in diesem Jahr von den
Vorwürfen erfahren doch das ist
umstritten Dominik Müller
Russell heute am späten Vormittag Anette
kurschuss persönliche Erklärung sie wird
nicht ihren Ämtern bleiben nach einer
Woche immer heftigerer Vorwürfe gegen
sie inzwischen hat sich die Lage derart
zugespitzt dass es für mich nur eine
Konsequenz gibt um Schaden von meiner
Kirche abzuwenden ich trete von beiden
kirchlichen leitungsämtern zurück in der
Sache bin ich mit mir im Reinen dem
gegenüber stehen die eidestattlichen
Erklärungen zweier Männer sie
bekräftigen Annette kurschuss bereits zu
ihrer Zeit als Pfarrerin in Siegen in
den 90er Jahren auf Missbrauchsvorwürfe
gegen einen Kirchenmitarbeiter
hingewiesen zu haben dieser Mitarbeiter
habe seine Stellung ausgenutzt um junge
Männer zu sexuellen Handlungen mit ihm
zu drängen kurschuss war mit dem
Mitarbeiter befreundet bis zuletzt gab
sie an sich zwar an ein generelles
Gespräch über ihn zu erinnern nicht aber
an die Vorwürfe sexuellen Missbrauchs
ihre Kritiker begrüßen den Rücktritt
heute da kurschuss mittlerweile das
Vertrauen der Betroffenen von
sexualisierter Gewalt in der
evangelischen Kirche verloren habe
im Sinne der Betroffenen ist der Schritt
wichtig und richtig den Frau Dr kchuss
gegangen ist und jetzt geht's darum dass
wir wieder weiter ohne Störungen im
beteiligungsforum sexualisierte Gewalt
arbeiten können kommissarisch folgt auf
kurschuss nun die Hamburger Bischöfin
Kirsten F im Amt fast 20 Millionen
Protestanten Leben in Deutschland nun
wird es auch darum gehen wieder
Vertrauen
herzustellen weg von und Nehmern hin zu
partnerschaftlicher Zusammenarbeit mit
diesem Ziel hat die Bundesregierung
heute zum großen afrikaagipfel geladen
anlass ist das Treffen der Initiative
compact with Africa 2017 von Deutschland
ins Leben gerufen 13 Staaten von Ägypten
bis zur Demokratischen Republik Kongo
beteiligen sich inzwischen und sagen
Reformen zu im Gegenzug für
Investitionen aus Berlin Andreas
küast es muss an diesem Morgen noch
schnell die Fahne von Mauritius
geliefert werden 13 Länder gehören zum
compact with Africa aber immer mehr
wollen dabei sein und so tauchen im
Berliner Herbst dutzende der mächtigsten
Herrscher Afrikas auf Präsident jisekedi
aus der Demokratischen Republik Kongo
100 Millionen Einwohner Präsident tinubu
aus Nigeria 200 Millionen Kanzler Scholz
aus Deutschland 83 Millionen ist hier
nicht als Entwicklungshelfer sondern als
ein interessierter Investor von vielen
afrikanischen Staaten die Grünen
Wasserstoff herstellen verspricht Scholz
große Mengen davon zu
kaufen viele afrikanische Länder haben
nämlich deutlich größere Potenziale für
erneuerebare Energien und die
wettbewerbsfähige Produktion von
Wasserstoff als wir bisher ist China der
mit Abstand größte Investor in Afrika in
Berlin will neben Deutschland auch
frankreich will die gesamte EU den
Handel verstärken die Ambitionen Europas
treffen sich mit dem Ehrgeiz etwa
Nigerias das gerade die größte
Ölraffinerie Afrikas eröffnet
hat wir reformieren unsere
Volkswirtschaft um ausländische
Direktinvestitionen zu ermöglichen wir
wollen die Nummer ein im Energiesektor
werden Europa wirbt um die Zuneigung
Afrikas vor allem Deutschland bietet
sich als Partner an die Zeiten haben
sich
geändert mehr als 250 Bombendrohungen
gab es in den vergangenen Wochen
bundesweit jetzt haben die Behörden zwei
Verdächtige ermittelt sie sollen für
einen Teil der E-Mails verantwortlich
sein die seit Mitte Oktober auch einige
größere Polizeieinsätze ausgelöst haben
ihr Ziel offenbar die Bevölkerung
verunsichern betroffen waren unter
anderem Schulen Medien und Unternehmen
ermittelt wird auch noch weitere
Personen jetzt Fußball lange war
exbundestrainerin Martina FOS
Tecklenburg abgetaucht jetzt ist sie im
ZDF exklusiv Interview ja dreieinhalb
Monate nach dem bitteren WM Vorrunden
aus und ihrer anschließenden Erkrankung
äußert sie sich erstmals öffentlich
emotional durchaus selbstkritisch und
lässt ihre eigene sportliche Zukunft
offen die ehemalige Bundestrainerin
spricht ehrlich und schonungslos über
Ängste depressive Zustände
ich habe 6 Kil abgenommen habe vier
Wochen hier gelegen konnte nichts
machen keine Menschen sehen irgendwo
raus weil ich gar nicht in der Lage war
viel geweint nach dem frühen WM aus
wollte sie zunächst als Bundestrainerin
weitermachen doch selbst die
Aufarbeitung des Geschehenen unmöglich
ich war nicht in der Lage konstruktiv
vernünftig zu sprechen ich war nicht in
der Lage eine wm-analyse zu machen ich
war krank das eine solche Aufarbeitung
nicht stattgefunden habe kritisierten
auch die Spielerinnen dafür zeigt
vtecklenburg Verständnis mit dfb-
Präsident Neuendorf will sie in nahe
Zukunft ein abschließendes Gespräch
führen ja und das ganze Interview mit
Martina fost Tecklenburg zu sehen bei
zdfheute.de und in der ZDF heute App ja
und jetzt zu den DFB Männern morgen das
Testspiel in Wien gegen Österreich nach
dem bitteren 2:3 gegen die Türkei
braucht Bundestrainer nagelsmann einen
Sieg sonst wäre der anfängliche Schwung
nach dem Trainerwechsel wohl völlig
verpufft drastische personelle
Konsequenzen wie es sie nach Niederlagen
schon mal gibt sind nicht zu erwarten
der Bundestrainer richtet den Blick auf
das Abschlusstraining und hofft auf
einen guten
länderspieljahresabschluss gar
Abschlusstraining ich schaue nur zu weil
ich einfach sehen wie viel spricht der
Spieler was wie sehen seine Augen aus
was ist für ein Eindruck noch mal so
werden auf jeden Fall nicht komplett
andere Ordnung oder andere Dinge spielen
sondernancen
anpassen Hinderung von Gegentoren bietet
sich die Chancenverwertung für die
Anpassung von Nuancen an ein Sieg zu
null fehlt noch in der kurzen erra
nagelsmann als Stimmungsaufheller nach
der Türkei Niederlage daheim und das
Spiel morgen Abend live bei uns im ZF zu
sehen 20:15 Uhr danke schön bitte zum
Schluss noch zu einer sehr
außergewöhnlichen WG die heute 25 Jahre
alt wird sehr weit weg international
bewohnt und als Ausgleich für die engen
Räume eine Lage mit wahnsinnsblick all
das bietet die Raumstation ISS los ging
es 1998 als das erste Modul ins All
geschickt wurde Montage bei 28 000 km
pro Stunde bis heute forschen dort
Auserwählte Wissenschaftler und
Wissenschaftlerinnen über Materialien
Medizin und auch mal ganz praktisch über
die
Schwerkraft das Wetter weiß nicht so
recht wohin es gibt Regen etwas Schnee
erst sinkende dann wieder steigende
Temperaturen mehr dazu hat gleich Katja
hornffer um : Uhr begrüßt Sie Marietta
Slomka im heute journal wir wünschen
Ihnen noch einen schönen Abend bis
morgen wenn Sie mögen auf
[Musik]
Wiedersehen guten Abend einige Flüsse
führen zurzeit ja recht viel Wasser das
sollte sich zur Wochenmitte wieder
ändern denn es kommt nicht mehr sehr
viel Regen hinterher heute hat es ja
noch hier zwischen Ostfriesland und der
Lausitz geregnet sonst waren Schauer
unterwegs und jetzt kommt das Tief Marco
heran und das bringt auch wieder dem
Westen und dem Südwesten Regenfälle der
Regen in Norddeutschland wird heute
Nacht mehr und mehr nachlassen und die
Temperaturen sinken auf Werte zwischen 8
und 2° um morgen bleibt es kühl bei uns
mit nur 6° an der Ostsee in der
Uckermark in den östlichen
Mittelgebirgen und am Alpenrand und
maximal 10° am Rhein das wird ein eher
trüber Dienstag mit Regenfällen und zum
Teil auch mit Schnee die schneefägrenze
sinkt in den östlichen Mittelgebirgen im
Laufe des Tages auch 600 m an den Alpen
liegt sie etwa um 1000 m am Nachmittag
kommt dann hier im Nordwesten hin und
wieder die Sonne zum Vorschein bei
Nordwind am Mittwoch kann es dann hier
in östlichen Bayern noch für einige
Schneeschauer reichen sonst geht's nach
nebelhäufig Sonnenschein bevor es von
Nordwesten schon wieder milder und
regnerisch wird der Donnerstag wird
stürmisch und milder und der Freitag
regnerisch guten Abend